'if my [ __ ] hello everybody my name
is markiplier and my name is Jack there
we go congratulations Jack you said your
name good job get rabies I don't know
wait what team do you want do you want
to be on the same team or officer teams
what we can do both or which one first
I'm gonna crush you so get on the other
team which is what I don't know you
joined blue I do an orange okay okay I
was gonna like you go first and then
we'll figure it out
Oh Casper's on my team also you've
played a lot more in this game than I
have I there's a lot of this I still
don't understand haha yeah well I mean
it's pretty simple you can move your uh
you can move your dude around bye whoa
wait I guess that's a win for me can't
cheer for that you didn't do anything
I did something I like Lumia look at you
off at the site doing I was there for
emotionals your own guy scored it on
your own goal dude I've come for you I
know ro frustrating as well when the
ball is so tantalizingly close and you
don't hit it yeah I know that feeling
Jack I hate it when balls are
tantalisingly close shut up holes easily
this is the first match we've done right
we did not practice and they did not
lose yeah exact weight a minute maybe
maybe I want to take that back you lose
did horribly dish Heuer layout is the
worst
and also he were so racist that last man
- you're so racist who was racist that
wasn't racist but you said you said he
were so racist oh okay this could be the
end of the world what could be the end
of the world my H he knows your hos it
could cost you the whole game look at
this look at what happened here this
horrible horrible ha ha and then my gun
oh [ __ ] oh good good team play because
we felt so bad for you because we know
how bad you're gonna do yeah sure yeah
you're gonna you guys you guys got a
teammate named boomer hey boomer yeah
well boomers about to blast all over
your face it'll make fun of over I'm
just waitin back here I'm waiting for
the sweet setup
hi sweet titties my last episode of five
nights at Freddy's I couldn't stop
talking about boobs oh I wanna see that
that was awesome nice yeah it's all tied
up thanks to people out of our own
control
yeah we're not good at this well I mean
we're kind of good at this
Oh titties I gotta stop talking about
boobs people think I have a problem you
thinking about boobs you just want to
keep flashing non-stop yeah oh I heard
did you did you I get all the complaints
from people just like Jack you know
marks mark seems to be a little
frustrated you wanna like do him a solid
give him a nice beach or something yeah
give him a bro job you know where am i
teammate I was about to follow it up I'm
glad I didn't the walls coming back
waters come back
I got [ __ ] this whole game is just me
practicing do
flips on my own actually contributing in
anyway I'm so close every time I know as
Aaron said he thinks many people think
this game is touch the ball in any way
it doesn't matter how or why just touch
ball people just want to get the ball
and hope that it goes in somewhere yeah
exactly and then hope that their name is
on the coal or lease as an assist in
some way or another just some way
knowing that they helped I will set it
up one two I'm the worst oh hi hey Bros
hey hey Bros anybody want a bro job over
here no good okay damn it
my toes are cringe to play this game
just your toes that's your heart what
hole butthole let me give that hole are
such good sniff there just to give it a
check oh no no no with the butt holes no
no anything hole I'm not putting my
clothes work all right now the gold ball
Homer ski in the town of dole you want
it you want to go find them all and then
sniff his butt hole oh I smell score go
okay you score goal what my butthole so
catched yes oh it's a sweet victory you
know I actually didn't hear I didn't
actually need to do anything but I just
wanted to put my name on it you know I'm
a team player that's what I am I play my
team like fools they do oh there you go
you actually got a guy playing goalie
over there it's actually pretty smart
somebody put me on the book there oh
sorry that was me from a distance
fingers this part of my glorious
commentary yes please touch ball in any
way please touch ball like jumping on
very I'll give me to like it hot a
little bit yes go go on go Samara go
tomorrow go not your birthday
Oh somewhere is good market tomorrow is
really really good
cool car - yeah Oh Dora wish I was that
guy yeah tomorrow was my favorite
character that's fake not really no I
didn't like that much you got a minute
to score two goals what can you do
come on cuz you did nothing there you
you are an expert at avoiding the ball
and everything going right underneath
the ball just a fraction of a second too
early yeah here we go oh [ __ ] I'm going
nowhere
nope no [ __ ] you Samara I love the way
to my face my little my little snowman
he does so much good for me that's good
for my soul doesn't do good for my team
but does good for my soul
sorry teammate you don't go to do good
for your team ah get out of here would
you say about my team huh you sass my
team boy God so bad no no not again come
on again oh I don't know what I mean you
do first
no where
yes this [ __ ] boomers like I'm just
hanging back here it's it's almost as if
he's using tactics and planning instead
of touch ball toss the ball anyway wait
wait you're a I super Gordo mine right
hey that's offensive or something
probably you've got a bunch of luck
everyone's cluster [ __ ] over here
alright that okay you hung back which
was smart and then okay alright I will
admit that was a good goal that's good
go Oh give me a compliment that's what I
get you look at handsome today
stupid the Irish way I got a gingerbread
man cool another decoration replacement
snowman you want to do it you want to do
another one yeah oh yeah man I love this
so much who needs who needs a let's play
with real people this time though that
way you can't blame the AI for being
terrible yeah we can only blame each
other for being terrible oh by the way
thanks to everybody so much for watching
as always we'll see you in the next one
[Music]